royal special on the death of the queen
coming up in the next hour
the king's speech
king charles expresses his gratitude to
the nation
and to his mother
in this his first public address as
monarch
to my darling mama
as you begin your last great journey
to join my dear late papa
i want simply to say this
thank you
the king also confirms that william and
kate will become prince and princess of
wales
and he expresses his love for harry and
megan
[Music]
his speech came at the start of a
special remembrance service at st paul's
cathedral
the new king and the new prime minister
this evening met for the first time
since they each assumed their
responsibilities
earlier gun salutes were fired at
military sites across britain
96 rounds fired one for each year of the
queen's life
[Music]
leaders from across the world joined
together to pay tribute to the late
monarch
to you
she was your queen
to us
she was the queen
good evening and welcome to this sky
news royal special on the death of the
queen
here as the night falls at buckingham
palace crowds of people have continued
to throng to pay their respects to the
late monarch
today the first opportunity to greet
their new king
king charles arrived here this afternoon
mingling with his subjects receiving
their good wishes
this evening the monarch made his first
address to the nation
he offered his gratitude to everyone for
the condolences they have offered
and to his mother for her life of
service
he also began to sketch out the future
of the royal family
with william and kate confirmed as the
new prince and princess of wales
in the next hour we'll be taking a pause
to reflect on the momentous events of
the past 24 hours
and we look forward to what it means for
the future of the royal family
and for our identity as a nation
but first our home editor jason farrell
reports on the new king
it is a moment of great change and for
one man more than any
charles arriving in the capital for the
first time as king
as his mother knew there is little time
for private grief in this role
there were hands to shake and those
unexpected moments to deal with
while songs to his health
[Music]
and though he has the comfort of a
nation sharing in his loss
he has a job to do
and it begins now here at buckingham
palace with this promise
as the queen herself did with such
unswerving devotion
i too now
solemnly pledge myself
throughout the remaining time god grants
me
to uphold the constitutional principles
at the heart of our nation
and wherever you may live in the united
kingdom or in the realms and territories
across the world
and whatever may be your background or
beliefs
i shall endeavor to serve you with
loyalty
respect
and love
as i have throughout my life
the new king has the toughest of acts to
follow at his mother's bed yesterday he
left balmoral this morning flying to
london with the queen consoled
your majesty prime minister
his first audience with a prime minister
was in the week his mother appointed her
he knew this day was coming but as he
told liz trust that didn't make it any
easier but it's been so touching
uh this afternoon when we arrived
all those people would come to
give their condolences your majesty very
very seriously
on behalf of all my family
i can only offer
the most sincere
and heartfelt thanks
for your condolences and support
they mean more to me than i can ever
possibly express
and to my darling mama
as you begin your last great journey
to join my dear late papa
i want simply to say this
thank you
thank you
for your love
and devotion
to our family
and to the family of nations you have
served so diligently all these years
may flights of angels
sing thee to thy rest
it was at his father's funeral the
family was last together and like many
monarchs before him charles's first
thought was to prepare ground for the
man who will come next prince william
i am proud to create him prince of wales
to whistle comrade
the country
whose title i've been so greatly
privileged to bear
during so much of my life and duty
with catherine beside him
our new prince and princess of wales
will i know
continue to inspire and lead our
national conversations
helping to bring the marginal to the
center ground
where vital help can be given
i want also to express
my love for harry and megan
as they continue to build their lives
overseas
so conciliation to harry who was last to
arrive in balmoral last night and first
to leave this morning his company to the
gangway an airport worker as he boarded
a british airways flight though he has
left the royal fold the king seems to
have given his blessing
her majesty prays that the blessing of
almighty god may rest upon your councils
just as the queen gave him hers handing
over responsibilities such as opening
parliament on her behalf showing us that
she believed in him and we should too he
may not be as iconically famous as his
mother but actually we know him better
his strengths his failings and his
opinions on things like climate change
his interventions have at times been
controversial seen as too political a
criticism he's addressed saying around
his 70th birthday he would not be a
meddling monarch
but as he takes on the role some hope he
won't keep his opinions to himself king
charles has been
an extraordinary voice way ahead of his
time for 50 years talking about
nature-based solution talking about
deforestation as challenges so i hope i
hope king charles will be able to
continue to
exert the moral authority he has thus
far to help us
win the battle of this crisis
as his mother showed there's a balance
between understanding the nation and
telling them what you think
and the success of a monarch is only
measured by how people respond to you in
that role
jason farrell sky news
skies royal commentator alastair bruce
joins me now alastair uh i guess that we
are probably through phase one
of the
uh
of the aftermath of the queen's death
now uh new king has spoken i think we're
getting used to
the
phrase king charles uh sketch out for us
what happens over the next two to three
days
well the moment of change between one
monarch and the next happened in the
heartbeat and the death of the queen but
there now needs to be a constitutional
process
of just reorganizing
all the procedures
and the most key of that comes tomorrow
with the accession council it's based in
history but its purpose is to put
formality to the change of rain and it
is then communicated in this document
that will be read out and signed
to different places around the united
kingdom and it's a reminder that they
didn't all have television in the old
days and there was the need to
communicate the change of monarch to the
people and that's the purpose of it but
it also creates another tick in the
process of formally changing from the
queen to the king
do we yet have any knowledge of when the
funeral will take place no none at all
but we're hoping to get much more
information on that
and the manner in which the king would
like
the days in between to be managed and
and exactly
how the queen will be recovered from
balmoral and brought ultimately down
to this part of the world and finally to
be buried so all that just needs to be
confirmed we know roughly what is
intended
but we don't know the formal way in
which it's to be done and we will wait
until we're told and then we can see we
know what needs to be done but we just
don't know the timings and tomorrow i
think it should become clear the queen
herself as we understand it will spend
at least some time still in scotland
probably in edinburgh
before being brought to london
where she'll rest in state what we know
is that at the moment she's at bar moral
and with her family and it is a quiet
time for the family to come to terms
with it like so many other families
choose to do in their own quiet way
and it's actually very cathartic i think
because when the family released the
queen
and her remains into the process that
will lead to her funeral in a way she
leaves them because she becomes the
possession of that greater family to
which she committed her whole life and
that is the people who wish to witness
and take part in the process of the
funerary events that lead to her final
burial so at that point
the population as a whole
uh
gets it gets involved television people
all of us watching it and seeing how
how many people will be able to visit uh
her lying in state and so forth well all
of that will be made clear but it's the
king's choice now
and he will have been briefed the earl
marshall who is the duke of norfolk is
responsible for putting together all the
ceremonial adobe parliament will need to
make sure that if she is to lion state
everything is ready and all that will be
announced as soon as they're ready it's
an extraordinary logistical exercise and
you you mentioned the um
uh the the duke of norfolk i mean this
is a sort of hereditary uh task i think
he's the 18th isn't he and all his
ancestors have all been responsible for
this kind of nearly all of them yes and
it it is hereditary but it it draws upon
many other full-time deliverers of of
huge capability not least from the lord
chamberlain's office in buckingham
palace from the armed forces uh from
other organizations the different
devolved organizations and also the
united kingdom government so all of it
is contributing to make sure that our
previous head of state is properly
carried to her grave and the king
himself what what can we expect to see
him doing during between the period
between now and the funeral there was
some talk that he would be uh going to
different parts of the united kingdom
during that period we believe that's the
intent that the king will get to meet
his kingdom and the four constituent
parts are known to us well scotland
northern ireland wales and england and
to find ways in which he can formally
arrive in those different parts and to
launch this new rain after
you know the queen's reign was so long
that when you have this punctuation
point of change it is important to mark
it and set it off in the right direction
i think that the king's statement today
absolutely did that
alistair thank you for the moment um the
prime minister and her predecessors paid
tribute to the queen today as
parliamentarians came together to mourn
liz trusts boris johnson and theresa may
all spoke in the commons sharing
personal anecdotes from their encounters
with her majesty
the prime minister described the queen
as one of the greatest leaders the world
has ever known
labour leader sakir stama said that
the loss of our queen robs this country
of its stillest point
its greatest comfort at precisely the
time
we need those things most
our next report comes from our political
editor beth rigby
as westminster pays tribute
queen elizabeth ii a constitutional
constant who saw 14 prime ministers come
and go
from churchill to cameron
mcmillan to may
thatcher to truss
anointing her 15th pm just two days
before she died devotion to duty to the
very end
a procession into parliament to lead
hours of tribute mps gathered to mark
the passing of a monarch mourned by
millions deeply missed in this place the
mother of all parliaments
[Music]
the new prime minister leading the
tribute
i have personally greatly valued her
wise advice
it was just three days ago of balmoral
that she invited me to form a government
and become her 15th prime minister
again she generously shared with me her
deep experience of government
even in those last days
mp sharing personal and professional
accounts of the queen who touched not
just their lives but the life of nations
around the world queen elizabeth created
a special personal relationship with us
all
that relationship was built on the
attributes
that defined her reign
her total commitment to service and duty
her deep devotion to the country the
commonwealth
and the people she loved
this former prime minister pained
she helped to comfort
and guide us
as well as the nation because
she had the patience and the sense of
history
to see that troubles come and go
and the disasters are seldom as bad
as they seem
and it was that indomitability
that humor
that work ethic and that sense of
history which together made her
elizabeth the great
a sentiment shared by another former
prime minister who knew the queen so
well
i am sometimes asked among all the world
leaders i met
who was the most impressive
and i have no hesitation in saying
but from all the heads of state and
government the most impressive person i
met was her late majesty queen elizabeth
ii
admiration and fond remembrance it was
all mixed in
with deep grief former foreign secretary
margaret beckett one of the few mps to
remember the queen's coronation nearly
overwhelmed
she was a remarkable person
a remarkable monarch
and we are the poorer for her going
[Music]
this prime minister spent 10 years by
her side and led the nation through the
loss of princess diana
if princess diana as you described was
the people's princess what was queen
elizabeth
queen elizabeth was
she was our monarch
but she was in a center matriarch uh the
mother of our nation
she represented that to people
her fast prime minister born a century
before her last the most remarkable
reign for the most remarkable of
monarchs her wise counsel will be deeply
missed beth rigby sky news westminster
during the queen's time on the throne
she welcomed more than a million and a
half people to royal palaces for garden
parties
she was the patron of almost 600
charities
it'd been estimated that a third of the
country had seen or met her in person
it was surprised then that huge numbers
of people have personal anecdotes of
their moment meeting the queen
katharina vitotshi has spoken to some of
those remembering the queen
far from palaces
pomp and princes
but no less part of a nation's mourning
churches like this one in warwick today
joined him with 96 chimes marking every
year of the late queen's life
solitary bells
in small parishes felt deeply moving
[Music]
as millions began to reflect on the
queen's singular life
my little girl was born just eight weeks
ago and i'm i feel really glad that she
was born during queen elizabeth's reign
um sadly she won't grow up sort of
knowing her in the way i did i'm here
because she remind me so much of my mom
and i live part-time in australia
and part-time here in uk
so i'm privileged to be here
at this moment
across the country today were signs of
this time
a time a transition most of us had never
seen
reflected in ways we might not have
expected
[Music]
a manchester cathedral some stopped just
to be part of it
but others came out of a sense of
genuine loss
jeffrey miller met the queen when he was
12 and an army cadet in wales he's still
in shock i couldn't believe it
you know i just stood in the front room
i
must admit there were tears coming down
my eyes
she was my queen she's my
commander-in-chief she'd always been
there ever since i've
been alive everything about her was
service to others
manchester was the last cathedral the
queen visited back in july last year the
dean remembers her delight when he
presented her with the cathedral's own
honey which they'd heard she liked in
her tea
i found a very flexible and able to
relate to
people at all levels
very pleasantly
always engaging always interested
and always with a smile on her face
and nothing was too much for her
she has been the nation's constant a
poll carried out in 2018 found that a
third of people across the uk had met or
seen the queen in person
over the coming days and weeks you will
see more places like this established
across the country some big some like
this one
small but all places for people to come
together to lay flowers to reflect and
remember a woman who they may never have
met but with whom everyone you speak to
feels a deep connection and with her
passing a deep sense of loss
and with loss comes for some uncertainty
about the monarchy's future
it's uh
it's a great loss
great loss
i just hope that
charles can live up to
what his mother is
obviously instilled in him
that would be a wonderful legacy for him
to carry forward
and what a legacy 70 years on the throne
forever in hearts
catherine of autopsy sky news in
manchester
the queen was described by the prime
minister today as the country's greatest
diplomat
and there are perhaps few places where
this talent was more powerfully deployed
than in helping to achieve an end to the
troubles in northern ireland
our senior ireland correspondent david
blevins reports now on the reaction in
northern ireland to her death
on shankle road in belfast they are
mourning their queen and the loss is
palpable she was a wonderful woman
she really was
i don't think there'd be another
monarch like her
i don't honestly
here in the loyalist heartland they're
proud to call themselves british
she was my commander-in-chief
she was my boss
for 22
years um best balls in the world
you've never found available
on the opposite side of the wall there's
no great outpouring of grief on the
republican folds road british queen
we're irish um but it didn't hit her
anything uh
sorry for her loss and sorry for her
family that's everybody's to the room
but it's not something i would you know
she was a mother she was a grandmother
but it's just not you know so sad on the
family
northern ireland has a nationalist first
minister designate sinn fein's michelle
o'neill said this wasn't the time for
anti-monarchy sentiment this is a time
for everybody to be respectful
um queen elizabeth has died there's a
family that is mourning her loss at the
end of the day she may have been the
queen of england but she was also a
mother and a grandmother and i think
people should be very respectful this is
a time for reflection this is the time
to be
respectful of all people and how they
feel right now
this tight security at the royal
residence in northern ireland it didn't
stop people coming to reflect at
hillsborough castle
she'll surely miss
everybody
it doesn't matter what religion whoever
you're from what color you are like the
millions of people around the world it's
the same state as me today
northern ireland is the corner of the
united kingdom where you'll find the
most loyal subjects of the crown
and the least loyal but even in this
divided society where some are not fans
of the monarchy there is broad consensus
that queen elizabeth herself personally
made an enormous contribution to the
search for peace
the queen led the way on reconciliation
her legacy challenges a new generation
to make the same pledge for peace
david blevins sky news in belfast
well across the country there has been a
flood of affection for the queen who
died yesterday at the age of 96
and as shinny marioki now reports
it is a grief felt across the
generations
it's been the first time and it
it was just
i can't describe it really i suppose a
fantasy really the way the gold coach
went by
a moment of pomp and ceremony from
another time one that signaled the start
of the second elizabethan era
seven decades later barry remembers that
day he watched a procession pass by as a
ten-year-old schoolboy
there was so much noise going on and
you know just waiting for her to come by
and it was when she came by you know the
big chairs and raws and people waving
flags and
it it was just wonderful
i'm still very sad quite honestly i
really am every time i get a spare
moment
i think about her
um
and her family of course
i just i don't know i don't know it's
going to be a hard act to follow
it really is
the queen was patron of england's
national bowls association and here at
this club in south london her loss feels
personal for many of the members who are
in their 80s
i think
some countries have got
a government and they've got a president
but they haven't got what we've got we
haven't got someone that everybody
admires more or less and other countries
admire
at this nearby school students several
decades younger are mourning someone
they've also known as a constant
the queen visited four times
pictures of her hair over the years
capture her longevity and the all she
inspired in onlookers
we're thankful
uh for her leadership
as i've been a cadet for many years i've
been honoring her i've been serving her
and it just feels weird that she's gone
i like to look up to her as part of the
military as a patron of our school but
also just as a woman it's so soon so
my thoughts are definitely still with
grieving the passing of the queen but
there is a level of excitement to a new
monarch a new era
as britain moves into a new moment in
its history one thing will unite the
young and the old a sense of hope for
the future [ __ ] marieke sky news
croydon in south london
well as we've been hearing earlier this
evening king charles addressed the
nation for the first time
in a few minutes we'll be speaking to
someone who worked closely with him when
he was prince of wales
but first let's listen again to that
address in full
i speak to you today
with feelings of profound sorrow
throughout her life her majesty the
queen
my beloved mother
was an inspiration an example to me
and to all my family
and we owe her the most heartfelt debt
any family could owe to their mother
for her love
affection
guidance
understanding and example
queen elizabeth was a life well lived
a promise with destiny kept
and she is mourned most deeply in her
passing
that promise of lifelong service
i renew to you all today
alongside the personal grief that all my
family are feeling
we also share with so many of you in the
united kingdom
in all the countries where the queen was
head of state
in the commonwealth and across the world
a deep sense of gratitude for the more
than 70 years
in which my mother as queen
served the people of so many nations
in 1947
on her 21st birthday
she pledged in a broadcast from cape
town
to the commonwealth
to devote her life
whether it be short or long
to the service of her peoples
that was more than a promise
it was a profound personal commitment
which defined her whole life
she made sacrifices for duty
her dedication
and devotion of sovereign never wavered
through times of change and progress
through times of joy
and celebration
and through times of sadness and loss
in her life of service
we saw that abiding love of tradition
together with that fearless embrace of
progress
which makes us great as nations
the affection
admiration and respect she inspired
became the hallmark of her reign
and as every member of my family can
testify
she combined these qualities with warmth
humor
and
an unerring ability always to see the
best in people
i pay tribute to my mother's memory
and i honor her life of service
i know that her death brings great
sadness to so many of you
and i share that sense of loss beyond
measure with you all
when the queen came to the throne
britain
and the world was still coping with the
privations
and aftermath of the second world
war and still living by the conventions
of earlier times
in the course of the last 70 years
we have seen our society become
one of many cultures and many
faiths the institutions of the state
have changed in turn
but
through all changes and challenges
our nation
and the wider family of realms
of whose talents traditions
and achievements i am so inexpressibly
proud
have prospered and flourished
our values have remained
and must remain constant
the role
and the duties of monarchy also remain
as does the sovereign's
particular relationship and
responsibility towards the church of
england
the church
in which my own faith is so deeply
rooted
in that faith and the values it inspires
i have been brought up to cherish a
sense of duty to others
and to hold in the greatest respect
the precious traditions
freedoms
and responsibilities
of our unique history
and our system of parliamentary
government
as the queen herself did with such
unswerving devotion
i too now
solemnly pledge myself
throughout the remaining time god grants
me
to uphold the constitutional principles
at the heart of our nation
and wherever you may live in the united
kingdom or in the realms and territories
across the world
and whatever may be your background or
beliefs
i shall endeavor to serve you with
loyalty
respect
and love
as i have throughout my life
my life will of course change
as i take up my new responsibilities
it will no longer be possible for me to
give so much of my time and energies to
the charities that issues
for which i care so deeply
but i know this important work will go
on
in the trusted hands of others
this is also a time of change for my
family
i count
on the loving help of my darling wife
camilla
in recognition of her own loyal public
service since our marriage 17 years ago
she becomes my queen consult
i know
she will bring to the demands of her new
role
the steadfast devotion to duty on which
i have come to rely so much
as my heir
william
now assumes the scottish titles which
have meant so much to me
he succeeds me as duke of cornwall
and takes on the responsibilities for
the duchy of cornwall
which i have undertaken for more than
five decades
today i am proud to create him prince of
wales
to wissu camry
the country
whose title i've been so greatly
privileged to bear
during so much of my life and duty
with catherine beside him
our new prince and princess of wales
will i know
continue to inspire and lead our
national conversations
helping to bring the marginal to the
center ground
where vital help can be given
i want also to express
my love for harry and megan
as they continue to build their lives
overseas
in a little over a week's time we will
come together as a nation
as a commonwealth and indeed a global
community
to lay my beloved mother to rest
in our sorrow
let us remember
and draw strength from the light of her
example
on behalf of all my family
i can only offer
the most sincere
and heartfelt thanks
for your condolences and support
they mean more to me than i can ever
possibly express
and to my darling mama
as you begin your last great journey
to join my dear late papa
i want simply to say this
thank you
thank you
for your love
and devotion
to our family and to the family of
nations you have served so diligently
all these years
may
flights of angels
sing thee to thy rest
joining me now is patrick harrison who
was press secretary to then prince
charles for more than a decade
good evening
good evening patrick um
this address
was
very personal
uh we heard the words my dear
my dear papa he talked about love and
devotion
was this
a new step for the king
i felt it was an incredibly heartfelt
address and a very personal one as i sat
there watching it earlier this evening
and again just now
i felt it was
the man that i worked with for over a
decade talking directly to me
i have no doubt it was the most personal
speech that he's ever written and and he
would have written that um and it
touched upon all the points that i felt
um needed to be included in that speech
balancing
the personal tribute to his darling mama
and to other family members
and then of course also reaffirming his
commitment to public duty
in some sense patrick he has been
preparing for this moment
for
70 years
i noticed the phrase my life will change
um
that's a remarkable thing for a man in
his what now 74th year to have to say
isn't it
yes it is um
and of course it will change because um
he is now our king but he has also given
50 years already of public service and
we should remember as as we think about
him stepping up into this new role that
he has been carrying out quite a lot of
the queen's role over the last few years
so obviously things like investitures
for many years but we saw him at the
state opening of parliament recently and
of course at the commonwealth heads of
government in in rwanda so there's quite
a lot of the role that he has already
done and then there'll be many things
that of course are new for for example
uh at the audience with the prime
minister which we saw for the first time
today
he um
so if
if there was a big if you like
announcement here
it was a confirmation that uh prince
william will become
prince of wales and uh
the duchess of cambridge will become uh
princess of wales and he made it quite
clear
that he no longer
expects to be able to spend the kind of
time and attention
that he is used to as you've just
pointed out on his charitable endeavors
and working with communities
and so on um
will that be a big shift for him
psychologically and organizationally and
also for those who've worked with him
during that time
well obviously it is a big shift i mean
he's an incredibly passionate individual
um who doesn't just see a problem but
wants to to fix it and of course he was
the man who took his naval uh severance
pay back in 1976 and set up the prince's
trust when everybody told him he
shouldn't do it um
but
this has been uh in the planning for
many years we've always known that this
terribly sad day would arrive and just a
few years ago his charities were
reorganized so that they could stand
more on their own feet if you like um
as he moves into
this new role
but for many people the big question
that arises out of all of that is that
this is a man who has never been
too shy to let us know what he thinks
about the great issues of the day
whether you agree with him or not you
couldn't mistake what he believed
of course
he's now i think implying in this that
he is now in this new situation do you
believe that that is going to be
possible for him to resist the
temptation
to do what he thinks obviously is right
and to let everybody know that
yes i do and he said so himself in a
documentary only a few years ago i think
it was 2018. um i i think he said
something like i'm not stupid i do
understand the difference between being
prince of wales and being monarch so
absolutely
i do and as i see say we've already seen
plenty of examples of him um
stepping into the lake queen's
role and i have no doubt that uh
that's now his focus and
we should also remember that uh his
immediate role is to lead the nation in
mourning and in grieving for a queen who
has who was our constant light for
generations all of us every single one
of us woke up this morning for the very
first time without the queen in our
lives and uh
so his immediate role is to help us all
not only in the united kingdom but in
the realms and the territories and the
commonwealth
come to terms with that and i don't know
about you but i've had various moments
during the day sort of waves of sort of
uh different emotions as we've gone
through the day somebody mentioned
christmas to me the other a few hours
ago and i thought gosh yes it won't be
the queen's speech this christmas so
there's an immediate role for him there
in in taking us through these first 10
days and and beyond uh
the funeral and as a compassionate and
empathetic man um he will do that
brilliantly
just very quickly uh patrick one of the
things that struck me rather forcibly is
that um the queen
in some of her last speeches spoke
moving about her faith
and i think we heard more about the new
king's faith
tonight than we have done in the past
well obviously um
talking about the importance of faith
was an important part of this speech but
i i think we've heard that many times in
the past
and uh and of course in the prince at
prince when he was prince of wales and
is now king a regular church goer um a
very spiritual uh uh a person and and uh
and and someone who has been very keen
um uh to increase interfaith dialogue i
remember doing uh many engagements with
him in the decade that i worked for him
on that particular theme
patrick patrick harrison the former
president press secretary to
uh
then prince charles thank you very much
indeed for your time
thank you
the address from the new king was
infused with hope for the future but for
those who gathered here and millions
across the country
the focus of their attention today was
on the past and the queen's life of
service and devotion to her duties
our royal correspondent rhiannon mills
reports
[Music]
a symbol of celebration throughout her
reign now bringing solemnity
gun salutes echoing across the country
from edinburgh to london
marking the end of an extraordinary life
flags everywhere were lowered
bells tolled up and down the country
mourning the death of the queen
the usual business of parliament has
stopped and ahead of speeches mps
reflected in silence
her late majesty queen elizabeth ii was
one of the greatest leaders the world
has ever known
she was the rock on which modern britain
was built
the united kingdom is the great country
it is today because of her
the commonwealth is the family of
nations it is today because of her
the prime minister's first audience with
the king happening in the same week his
mother appointed her
on mourning her death we have looked
back remembering a glamorous young queen
who would become for so many the
nation's grandmother
and so something very special has gone
people joining a collective sense of
loss
hundreds queueing in the hope of getting
a seat at a special ceremony at some
pools
just a most inspirational
positive
wonderful woman
with a sense of humor
a sense of loyalty
to her people and her family
i'm one of the best mothers any country
can ever have i will certainly never
know another female monarch and she
probably won't either um and that was a
strange thing to think about especially
being a little girl you know she was
such a
you know a strong constant for all of
these years
and you know and that's gone and that's
that's sad whether you support the
monarchy or not
in a place of sanctuary where only
months ago her family and friends had
remembered her remarkable service and
celebrated her platinum jubilee the
congregation were encouraged to look to
her example
as we mourn her loss
give thanks for her life
and reorientate ourselves as individuals
and a nation to life without her majesty
may her words remind
us
of the power and strength
to be found in coming together
[Music]
much about the coming days has been
scripted and planned but it is the
public response to this moment that will
mark its place in history
rhiannon mills sky news at buckingham
palace
our correspondent laura bundock is with
me now
um
laura
it must have been incredibly daunting
for the new king
what struck you most about his address
tonight well i think you're right this
is a speech that mattered
it needed to say a lot and i think it
definitely did we have a king
speaking for the first time to people as
monarch and we also have a son
speaking paying tribute to a mother my
darling mama as he put it and i think
you could tell there was a sense of
nervousness there
uh that this was the most important
speech he'll ever make in his life a
real choking with emotion it was it was
moving it felt personal and of course
the tributes to the queen to her sense
of duty to her devotion to the role and
then a glimpse into what the new reign
will look like we now have a new prince
of wales we have a princess of wales i
think there was a very touching tribute
to his queen consort camilla and
touching words to to megan and harry
as well there but i think most of all
this sense of change here we have a man
who is now having to move from a
political prince a prince who spoke out
on issues close to his heart
to now having to become the man who will
be a meaningful monarch and the man who
has to figure out what it is his people
people here in the commonwealth wants
and what they need from him as monarch
so it's hardly surprising when we heard
him say to liz trust that it was a day
he'd been dreading because
clearly he knows he has to keep going
and that he also knows his reign will
not be the seven decades of his mother
so he needs to decide
how he will make it matter how he will
make it meaningful what is it that will
define his reign
laura thank you so much
now to you she was your queen to us
she was the queen
the words today spoken in english of
french president emmanuel macron
echoing the sentiment of leaders across
the world as they paid tribute to the
queen her majesty undertook
266 official overseas visits in total
including 100 state visits and she
played host to some of the world's most
famous leaders from charles de gaulle to
nelson mandela
our europe correspondent alan parsons
reports from paris on the tributes from
around the world
here's how the world paid tribute the
sydney opera house a dazzling portrait
in rio
christ the redeemer lit up in new york
the empire state building
but in paris the glitters of the eiffel
tower were turned off the world a little
darker
president macron came to the british
embassy to sign a book of condolence he
spoke of the queen as a close friend of
france
to you
she was your queen
to us
she was the queen
to us all
she would be with us forever
outside the embassy flowers were being
laid and among those we spoke to sadness
and respect
i'm sad yes because she's the only queen
i
i knew in my lifetime she had her duty
as prime concern and in a democracy
where you have five
five year term it's something that's
really striking
the queen visited france 13 times more
than any other country
here in france there really is a
cocktail of sympathy and affection and
it is replicated all over the world
the truth is that politicians may come
and go but the queen was something
unique in global public life she spent
seven decades representing britain all
over the world
america has lowered its flags to
half-mast president biden saying the
queen had defined an era
and north of the border an emotional
tribute from canada's leader
canada
is in mourning
she was one of my favorite people in the
world
and i will miss her so
in death confirmation of the queen's
extraordinary fame
messages from across the whole world
from the pope from china the united
nations even from vladimir putin
[Applause]
and in new zealand that most profound of
honours a hacker to remember the queen
in an era of quick celebrity
the world has remembered a public figure
who endured for so very long
adam parsons sky news paris
we can speak now to rose hudson wilkin
the bishop of dover who served as
chaplain to the queen for more than a
decade
good evening bishop rose thank you for
joining us
hello hello we
we heard
from the king tonight
uh
quite a lot about
his faith and a solemn pledge
to what extent do you think
this is part of
what we're going to see over the next
period of morning and uh into his reign
how important do you think this issue of
faith is going to be to him
well you know i i believe very strongly
that faith was
a bedrock of her majesty the queen
and it is clearly something that she has
shared
with her family
um i have no reason to doubt
our new king
um when he says that this is important
to him
and something that is important to to
one
isn't just something we look at
occasionally and then put it away
um it is something that we live by
we've heard a lot of her words uh in the
last 24 or 36 hours one of her speeches
struck me rather
as rather significant in this respect
she spoke about her own faith anglican
faith but she said that the point about
that for her as queen
was that
her faith
was an expression of the place of faith
all kinds of faith in and indeed she
said people who don't have faith in
society
to what extent do you think
she was important in
establishing that
idea that faith has a legitimate and
important part to play in a modern
society
very important you see what what we've
seen in our culture is a sense that oh
we've grown up we don't need that thing
called faith what's that you know it's
not scientific so we don't need it and
and what she has certainly proved in her
own life is that this has been a bedrock
for her
but but also there is something else
when you are confident about your faith
it makes you look outwards it makes you
create space
and enable others to also feel that they
too
can talk about their own faith and can
profess their own faith so it really is
important that we understand that that
having one's faith and
having confidence in that faith is not
something that prevents others but
actually enables others to to say
who they are as people of faith
constitutionally the sovereign now kings
charles is
a defender of the faith by which is
meant the established
church the anglican church
some years ago there was some
public debate about whether he might be
named defender of the faiths plural as a
reflection of our more diverse
uh multicultural society in which
significant numbers of people are
muslims they are buddhists there are
people who have a different kind of
faith perhaps not
recognizably part of an organized
tradition
do we expect to see any of that
between now and his coronation
i i believe that what we will see is
someone who will
define for himself
without the press or others telling him
what is the appropriate
um way to go he will define for himself
what that means and how he will practice
that but as we've already heard and seen
and and and we also saw that in
her majesty the queen
that they
enabled others of other faith
recognizing we are here we are living in
a society where we are multi-religious
and so we are saying don't go in a box
with your faith let's all be able to
express our faith
i know that you spend a lot of time uh
with her majesty and uh
you knew her personally one of the
interesting things that i think some
people are beginning to talk about is
the extent to which
um essentially the country
seems to feel that it's this has been a
shock it's everybody's been prepared for
it but perhaps not ready
do you think that there what do you
think has essentially unleashed that
well of affection concern
that sense of of shock oh can i just say
that i'm sure that there are lots more
people who have spent much more time
with her than i have but but but coming
back to this point here is someone who
has been a constant in our lives we wake
up she's been there you know people who
are grandmothers have known of her and
and she's been there
constantly and she has been
not only there physically but very
present in the way that she has lived
in the way she has brought communities
together and i think that the morning we
are seeing now
is real
because people recognize perhaps for the
first time
that maybe we've taken this for granted
and also that we will not have that
from her
and and so there is sadness
bishop rose
thank you very much for your time thank
you for joining us this evening
thank you
before we go we have a special
additional episode of the sky news daily
with neil patterson available now which
follows the stories of those who today
travel to buckingham palace you can
listen to it by scanning the qr code on
screen right now or by subscribing for
free
wherever you get your podcasts from
that's all for us from this special
program
coming up next is news at 10 with dermot
monaghan with all of today's
developments good night